let's say that we are told that 495 is
equal to 621 - blank
what would blank be pause this video and
see if you can figure that out okay now
let's do this together and one technique
is to try to visualize this on a number
line
495 is what you get when you subtract
something from 621 so let me put those
two numbers on a number line so let me
do the number line like this so we're
going to start at 621 and subtract blank
to get to 495 so if this is 621 we're
going to subtract some amount to get to
495 so let's say this right over here is
495 now what amount did we subtract so
here we are subtracting blank that's my
blank over there and so we need to
figure out what that is so how do you go
from 621 to 495 well one way that my
brain does it first we can subtract 21
to get to 600 so let me do minus 21
would get us to 600 then we could
subtract another hundred to get to 500
so then we could subtract another
hundred so minus one hundred to get us
to 500 and then to go from 500 to 495 we
would subtract another five so to go
from 621 to 495 and I picked these
numbers intentionally I picked 21 to
subtract to get to 600
I picked a hundred to get to 500 and
then I picked five to get to 495 I
subtracted a total of twenty-one then I
subtracted one hundred then I subtracted
five so I subtracted one hundred I
subtracted twenty-one and I subtracted
five and so how much did I subtract in
total so let me put it this way this is
the same thing as 621 minus these things
that's equal to 495 so in total let's
see if I subtract twenty one and I
subtract five that is subtracting 26 and
so I subtract one hundred
and 26 so I subtracted a total of 126 so
495 is equal to 621 minus 126 let's do
another example let's say we want to
figure out if we if someone tells us
blank
- 435 is equal to 210 what is blank in
this situation well this is a little bit
different now
because now we're not trying to figure
out what to subtract from the larger
number in this situation we're trying to
figure out the larger number the larger
number minus something is equal to 210
but as always it's useful to draw this
on a number line just to make sure we're
thinking about things in a reasonable
way so we're going to start at blank
take out 335 and then we're going to get
to 210 so we're starting here maybe I'll
put a question mark there so we know
that point we're starting there we are
subtracting 435 so that's minus 435 and
we are getting to 210 so to figure out
blank we could go the other way around
we could start at 210 and then just add
and then just add 435 so what's 210 +
435 well there's many ways of doing it
by encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can work that out
well one way to do it is first we can
add 400 I'll do this in another color
just for a little bit of a variety so
first I'll add 400 so if I add 400 plus
400 that would get us see if you had 400
to that that would get you to 610 and
then if I add 30 to that so if I add
plus 30 and I haven't drawn it exact but
this is just to help us think about
things that's three more tens and I
already have 110 so 10 plus 30 is 40 so
I guess this is 640 and then I'm going
to add the five so this right over here
if I add 5 to it is 645 so there you
have it
645 -
435 is equal to 210